all right carter sit up big smile look
straight in the camera
action black excellence is still at an
all-time high when i originally created
the campaign it was just supposed to
last for black history month i wanted to
reimagine black history figures like
rosa parks or dr king in the likeness of
a child i really wanted to create a way
to amplify those voices and amplify
those accomplishments so that not only
during black history month but just in
general we could really just pause and
say you know what it really is because
of them
that we can
[Music]
all right you can say that again you're
going to read it with a little
confidence okay my name is younique
jones gibson i'm the founder of because
of them we can say kamala harris and
cory booker ran for president because of
them we can is a multimedia platform
that celebrates black excellence there's
so much thai history that really isn't
being explored and talked about outside
of the confines of black history month
i started because of the weekend in 2013
it was actually chase who inspired the
genesis of the campaign
the first photograph that i took was of
a little muhammad ali and i thought wow
it'd be really cool to do this as a
photo campaign for the month of february
some of the original images included
spike lee
harriet tubman rosa parks malcolm x
savion glover
here we are seven years later and it's
still going and still growing let's talk
about a little more energy come on ready
it's been two years since our previous
news video people just saw it and loved
it we decided to bring all the kids back
our don lemon our angela rye our april
ryan our burkari sellers and andrew
gillum so on shoot day it's fun it's
high energy i want it to be an amazing
experience so i work really hard to pump
them up
high-five them give them hugs with sugar
so that they know this is fun
are you ready to be april ryan
yes it's so cool because my little don
lemon in his mind is still a little don
lemon my little angela wright in her
mind is still angela rye and so that
means something because they have a
positive person that they can associate
a memory with
look what i'm here with
one of the cool things that happened
while we were here tell her what you're
doing being you angela rye she facetimed
in because i told her that her mini-me
was here and so that was definitely a
burst of good energy for all the kids
[Laughter]
i'd say i've worked with well over 1500
kids in the past seven years through the
because of them we can't platform we've
built up a following on social that
boasts over a million followers but we
also reach tens of millions of people
online every month because of them we
can is important because it's a real
reflection of who we are of what we've
done what we're doing and what our
potential
is in this world
[Music]
you